Good morning everyone. I am Arun Pradeep from CSE department. Currently pursuing
third year of computer science engineering in Panimala Engineering College.
And when it comes to handling the pressure, I am
very good in it. Why? Because I don't actually think too much
about the result. I used to think about the process I am working on.
I used to think about that
life is not about ending or the output.
It's about the journey. So I just enjoy the process.
And whatever they love to do, I will do. And this
is how I handle the pressure. I don't care too much about the external
pressure. And whenever I feel
so pressure I just quit
everything for a moment and think about what it would be if
everything got solved. And this is how I actually do things.